white house press secretary and national
heartthrob kaylee mcinanny is coming
under fire from the mainstream media
because she made a comment that's
ridiculous
it's outrageous it's silly it's
preposterous
it's completely correct kaylie mcenany
when she was asked about president
trump's
walk from the rose garden through
lafayette park to stand with the bible
at st
john's church with the riot which the
writers had tried to burn down the night
before
she compared that moment to winston
churchill
surveying wartime england
why did the president feel it was
important to go walk over there through
the park into the church
it was extremely important look the
president wanted to send a very
powerful message that we will not be
overcome
by looting by rioting by burning this is
not what defines america and going and
standing by
saint john's church was a very important
moment and i would note that through all
of time
we've seen presidents and leaders across
the world who have had leadership
moments and very powerful um symbols
that were important for a nation to see
at
any given time to show a message of
resilience and determination like
churchill we saw him inspecting the
bombing damage it sent a powerful
message of leadership to the british
people and george w bush
throwing out the ceremonial first pitch
after 9 11 and jimmy carter
putting on a sweater to encourage energy
savings and george h.w bush signing
the americans with disabilities act
flanked by two disabled americans and
for this president
it was powerful and important to send a
message that the writers the looters the
anarchists they will not prevail
that burning churches are not what
america is about
and that moment holding the bible up is
something that has been widely hailed by
franklin graham and others
and it was a very important symbol for
the american people to see that we will
get through this
through unity and through faith bingo
exactly right
some people are comparing the two photos
president trump
walking through the park and winston
churchill talking to people as he's
surveying war
war-torn england and they're saying oh
yeah what a
what a ridiculous comparison here
winston churchill didn't need the police
to clear out the park with
with tear gas which by the way they
didn't use and he didn't need all of
that it went churchill's
you know so much stronger churchill is a
singular man in history
but actually the only difference i can
see there is in the photo
with winston churchill talking to the
people in war war ravaged england
all of the people are smiling and nice
and well-behaved
and they're not looting and rioting and
killing people
they're not insurrectionists the enemy
is outside the country
in in that case whereas with president
trump they had to clear the park out
because there were rioters anarchists
communists killers thiefs
looters who have been burning down
american cities
coast to coast for the last six
days the people causing the damage and
the destruction the threat to the public
safety
is here in the case of president trump
trump could have just gotten into a
motorcade and headed over to the church
he didn't need to walk
the fact that he walked through that
front door then walked
through lafayette park one of you seen
that whenever you seen a u.s president
walking through a lafayette park
and then he got to the church and he
didn't give a speech he stood outside
the church
and held up the bible that image is
beautiful and obviously president trump
who's
incredibly media savvy knew the value of
that image
and specifically on this question
because the question
that the media and the liberal
establishment is used to encourage these
riots and the riots themselves
are largely about race and racial issues
and by holding up that bible what trump
is showing is the
sole source of anti-racism in the
history of the world
and the basis for the only civilization
that has ever opposed racism
in the history of the world that is
contained within
the bible that comes from our christian
culture
which we're now running on the fumes on
in this secular society
hugely important moment the fact that
trump led the march
across lafayette park he didn't have
bodyguards and secret service all around
him
he led it to show that there's no fear
and to show by holding up
that very book the only way that we will
possibly move forward
and come together as a country a great
moment
and an historic one
[Music]
you